[ __ ] you know Rosen frozen frozen why
are not even wrapped
where are the burgers I mean it just
doesn't look anything like a burger that
was processed like that and stamped
impress you can just tell right Wow
Brett come with me yeah how's the
fettuccine not the best general sorry um
burgers a Burger cooked here locally
would you expect that to be frozen or
fresh the burgers not frozen
it's the patties and everything come in
frozen when you thought out is that like
neither equal before L so it's not the
frozen that it comes in frozen yeah you
thought out and that so that your
customers is not frozen burger well
stay there let me just show you I'm
waiting for him to come back he's gonna
ream me on something oh boy here we go
mm-hmm so there's your burgers is it
frozen thank you
well you husband said it wasn't know
what I mean no it's it's frozen of
course I never said that it wasn't it we
thought out here it comes in frozen yeah
it's still a frozen burger there's no
such thing as a fresh burger at least at
least here in Eastern Washington
we cannot get fresh there's no print can
you find me the burger come with me yeah
good evening welcome please come in out
of the cold your dinner
quick question do you love a burger yes
would you expect them to be made fresh
here or frozen you gotta tell them what
I tell them fresh all the way now should
we tell them the truth I mean that's
what we want oh we we sell our burgers
come in frozen and we thought out but
thorn the mouse doesn't make them fresh
thank you appreciate it
thank you thank you thanks for coming
you guys welcome ladies hey folks how
are you quick question coming out for
dinner would you expect a frozen burger
to be served here tonight or fresh one
fresh you tell us I tell them I'll let
you tell them oh come on you earned the
place well we all of our beat that we
get in burgers it comes in frozen our
burgers and we and we thaw them out
which in his mind convinces him it's
fresh does that make it sound any better
yeah thank you we're still glad to have
you thank you you bet
oh my
after Brent tried to convince me that
there were no fresh burgers in town I
walk directly across the street and
ordered one
[Music]
nice to see go into a restaurant like
this would you expect your burgers to be
fresh or frozen burgers come in frozen
and we thaw him out that's the story
thank you so that is a lamb burger fresh
I'm getting sick to death of this denial
denial denial you've been making up
[ __ ] all [ __ ] day yes yes you
have always start with the same thing to
say first of aggressive condescending
inappropriate and stubborn oh absolutely
the staff the way you treat them you're
just scared about employer team is gonna
tell you the truth that is [ __ ]
because you don't like them for guarding
you with the truth yes you fire them Oh
find out anybody I heard that you fired
your son oh [ __ ] you don't even know the
[ __ ] story he was having some issues
Gordon and I told him where the alcohol
problem I was aware of that right I was
trying to save his life
yeah my brother's a drug addict we put
him in rehab seven times unsuccessfully
I don't give up on him
but what I'm more concerned about is
that nothing's affecting you it's like
we're doing great in general in the
police runs quite well yeah oh my god